790 in the Vikings are trading
peacefully whilst trading in Britain
they would have been made aware of these
wonderful places called monasteries
which were filled with treasure had no
defenses barring a few monks and often
sat right on the coast shockingly
dumping unbelievable wealth and easy to
reach places attracted the attention of
people who wanted such wealth and in 793
a monastery called Lindisfarne in
Northumbria was ransacked by Seabourn
raiders over the next decade more of
these raids occurred that the
monasteries of monk Weymouth Jarrow and
Iona facing the same fate alongside many
coastal settlements so before we begin
the term Viking comes from the old
english word Vica which means pirate not
all viking - a Raiders however some were
soldiers and Nobles who simply served
their Lords much in the same way the
anglo-saxons would have for the sake of
simplicity the term Viking will be used
to mean all Scandinavian soldiers and
settlers who operated in Britain during
this period the Vikings consisted of two
major groups the first were the Danes
from Denmark who operated mostly in what
is now England the second group were the
Norse from Norway who focused on the
northern coast of Britain as well as
Island and Wales the raiding continued
in the decades following Lindisfarne
culminating in what is called the great
heathen army landing in East Anglia in
865 the size of this army is debated but
it was the largest army the Vikings had
ever assembled and was extremely potent
it was led by two men half-down
ragnarson alongside his brother Ivar the
boneless so the East Anglian spade the
Vikings off and agreed to let them
winter there providing they didn't kill
everyone in 866 the great heathen army
headed into Northumbria and quickly
seized day off of it or York as it's now
known incidentally the reason that it
was so easy for the Vikings to get to
York was because they sailed there
Viking longships were considerably
faster than walking or riding and this
was made even easier by the fact that
the English coast line did not look like
this as it does today but in fact it
looked like this the Vikings had arrived
at an opportune moment because
Northumbria was in the midst of a civil
war which or two kings eller and Osbert
tried to out murder each other for the
throne upon realizing the Vikings are in
Northumbria they're both united their
force is a-march-da New York where they
and their armies were swiftly butchered
after this the Vikings placed a puppet
king called edge bow on the throne and
many of the nobles of Northumbria fled
North which split the kingdom into two
the northern half had his capital at
bebbanburg
modern-day bamboo whereas the southern
kingdom was centered at York over the
next couple of years the Vikings marched
through Murcia and they seized the
important city of snotting him or
Nottingham as it's now called a combined
force from Mercy
and Wessex attempted to retake the city
but they failed in 869 the great heathen
army went south into East Anglia again
but this time its King Edmund refused to
pay them off and so met them in battle
Edmund was subsequently captured and
executed the zoning him the moniker
Edmund the martyr in 871 some
reinforcements arrived from Scandinavia
and the Vikings turn their attention to
Wessex this invasion didn't come to much
when the king of Wessex Ethelred
defeated the great heathen army before
dying and being succeeded by his brother
Alfred who then paid the Vikings off the
great heathen army continued moving up
and down the country over the next few
years a mercy was eventually toppled in
874 the Viking army then split up with
guff from heading south into Wessex and
half down taking his bound north to
fight the Picts and the Britons the
anglo-saxon chronicle states that after
defeating the Picts half Dan shared out
the lands of the Northumbrian and they
proceeded to plan to support themselves
so it can be said from this passage in
the anglo-saxon chronicle that the
Vikings in half Dan's portion of the
army had permanently settled the land in
Northumbria and for many this is
considered the beginning of what is
called the Danelaw so the Danelaw as the
name suggests was the part of Britain
which found itself subject to the Danes
and their laws of course some parts of
Britain would come under the control of
the Norse but no distinction is made him
the Danelaw was by no means some great
unified territory that sat in opposition
to the anglo-saxons living next door it
was politically divided and there was a
lot of cultural blending that went on in
the few years after Halfdan settlement
by which it is meant that he became King
and then took everyone else's land and
gave it to his men the eastern portion
of Mercy was divided into what is known
as the five boroughs each of these
burrows was ruled by a noble quarter yar
the five boroughs were centered on five
towns
Nottingham Lincoln and Stamford
Leicester and Darby all of these towns
would go on to be extremely important
regional centres later on which is why
all of them borrowing Stamford have
their own counties named after them as
for East Anglia Guthrum who had just
been baptized as F of Stan after being
defeated by King Alfred of Wessex became
its King the creation of the Danelaw saw
many social demographic cultural
religious and economic changes to the
areas set up by the Danes
for starters Danish law stated that the
life of an Anglo Saxon was worth less
than that of a Dane our first treaty
with Gouffran stated that in their
respective kingdoms Danes and
anglo-saxons were to be viewed as equals
this equality did not apply to Britons
though who were still seen as inferior
one aspect of Danish rule was its
pronounced effect on urbanization after
the settlement of York by the day
it saw a steady period of population
growth and importantly the city's
commercial center expanded during part
two York's useful location along the
route between Scandinavia and Ireland
and partly due to the fact it was under
Scandinavian control York's importance
in international trade grew swiftly
workshops sprang up and housing
shortages led to the building of
two-story buildings which shows just how
to fill up fighting urban planning could
be this expansion went hand-in-hand with
the economic prosperity that was seen
under Danish rule a part of this
prosperity came from the fact that the
Danish had settled and thus were no
longer pillaging and stealing everything
the uptick in trade meant that some in
the Danelaw began to mint their own
coins which gave the kings of the
Danelaw greater legitimacy overseas
so the Dane Lord did not just attempt to
keep up with its neighboring anglo-saxon
kingdoms but formed its own Anglo
Scandinavian culture fortunately for the
Vikings their language Old Norse was
somewhat mutually intelligible with Old
English which meant that there weren't
major barriers between them and the
native Anglo Saxons this does not mean
that there weren't major cultural
differences between the two ethnic
groups the largest of which was religion
when they arrived the Vikings were
pagans worshipping numerous gods such as
Odin Freya or Thor which was problematic
for the Christian Anglo Saxons and Celts
already living in Britain when they
first arrived the Vikings had no qualms
with raiding and destroying church
property in Britain churches were the
main centres of learning at this point
which meant that many cultural works and
laws did not survive the Viking raid in
which is why so much more is known about
places such as Wessex than East Anglia
or Northumbria evidence of major
disruption to the church in pagan lands
is seen by looking at many bishoprics
for example the bishopric and east
anglia didn't reappear for nearly 100
years after Viking appearances and the
bishopric of Lindsey never returned
pagans and Christians living
side-by-side did create a multi
religious society many Vikings took
Christian Anglo Saxon wives which meant
that since women were in charge of
raising children many would have had at
least a semi Christian upbringing this
coupled with the power and wealth of the
church meant that generally pagan
beliefs were replaced by Christian ones
within a couple of generations one of
the reasons that this is believed is
that Viking style burial is a few and
far between in the areas of the Danelaw
but this problem is compounded by the
fact that no one knows just how many
Vikings actually settled Britain it
could have been that the Vikings simply
displaced the ruling anglo-saxon class
or the after settlement they brought
their families over with them one way of
potentially telling how many Viking
settled is by looking at place names as
a very general rule the names of Viking
founded towns tend to end in either B or
Thorpe such as
bo stanthorpe whereas anglo-saxon towns
tend to end in turn ham or burry such as
Luton Buckingham on Shaftesbury there
are many exceptions to this rule however
since many were simply renamed after the
Viking settles such as they offer WIC
which became your Vic there are parts of
the British Isles there were many Viking
style burials however and these are
found for the most part in Scotland and
Ireland in the areas settled by the
Norse by the time of Gotham's defeat by
Alfred the Shetland and Orkney Islands
have been seized and settled by the
Norse the Norse move further down the
western coast of Scotland conquering the
Hebrides before reaching the Isle of Man
island and Wales in Ireland the Vikings
founded the fortification of Dublin in
841 which was abandoned in 902 and
settled again in 917 due to its central
location Dublin as it was later known
quickly became an important trading city
particularly in the cargo of slaves with
respect to anglo-saxon politics Dublin
was an extremely important center since
he gave the Danes potential allies but
it's important to remember that all
Vikings were by no means allies an
example being that due to the raiding by
the Norse from Dublin the Danish
Northumbrian offered to make an alliance
with mercier against them so the Viking
position in what would later become
England was weakened during the reign of
Alfred the great successor Edward the
elder alongside his sister Ethel fled
through a series of conflicts Edward was
able to slowly wear away at the borders
of the Danish into a series of victories
allowed him to annex all of these lands
by 9:18 in 927 Northumbria fell to
Edwards successor Ethel Stan and thus
the only remaining Viking powers in the
British Isles was that of the Norse the
Norse continued raiding and also
occasionally cemented alliances with the
Britons such as those at the kingdom of
Strathclyde or the sort of kind of now
semi unified kingdom of Alber which
would soon become Scotland Northumbria
would not stay under English rule
without hiccups though there was a
series of conquests Andry conquests of
York by the English in the Norse over
the course of the mid temps in tree the
most famous North King of York was a man
called Erik blood axe two things about
Erik one he had previously been deposed
as the king of Norway and - his name is
awesome but probably wasn't used by his
contemporaries his first reign began in
97 shortly after a odd read became King
of the English the Northumbria nobility
weren't too keen on being a part of the
United England and they took Erik as
their King in response a after it
invaded and soon ravaged most of
Northumbria and erich supporters
abandoned him presumably because dying
is terrible Erik ran away and was soon
replaced by the king of Dublin Olaf who
reigned between 9 49 and 9
fifty-two before himself being kicked
out in favour of Eric again little is
known about what kind of ruler Eric was
but he was ousted again in 954 before
being killed in battle
Heydrich then took over the ruling of
Northumbria which would never again be
an independent kingdom and was
incorporated into the kingdom of the
English to some the removal of Eric
blood ax marks the end of the Danelaw
and the genuine beginning of England as
a United political and cultural entity
but there are some problems with this
the first is that Danish law continued
to be used long after Northumbria lost
its independence the second is that 954
was not the end of Scandinavian activity
in Britain not by a longshot
Northumbria is law of T to the house of
Wessex was not guaranteed and many who
lived in the old day know were not
opposed to the idea of a Danish ruler
returning and the return of a Danish
ruler was something they would certainly
get I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching if you'd like to
know more about the day know there are
some book recommendations in the
description
you